je t'aime tu peux encore vous êtes en
état d'arrestation pour le meurtre de
roland leroy
mais c'est un coup monté et sétois
papillon a fait du pognon fou tu en
trouves sinon tu t'es bad rajat mecs se
troue louis de gare
ce type sont millionnaires il tiendra
pas longtemps mon petit doigt me dit que
tu peux être dangereux
garnements envie je financerai toute
évasion tu pourras organisez vous
appartenait à l'administration
pénitentiaire de la guyane française
évoque un moyen de s'évader
il ya toujours un moyen c'est que nombre
d'entre vous restent de s'échapper vous
en paix ne vous gênez pas
si vous survivez à votre tentative ce
sera la perpétuité sur l'île du diable
les choses étranges s'y passe surtout
pour ceux qui s'accrochent à l'espoir
patriat
[Musique]